[Música]
creo que cierre los ojos un momentico
vas a imaginarte a una compañera tuya
tiene 15 años
se llama Alice
te la vas a inventar
[Música]
comenzamos a hablar Que porque me
internaron acá ya se sentía bien o sea
sabía que nada le iba a pasar y no le
desearía nada a nadie la calle porque la
calle es calle
algún secreto que te haya contado Alice
que fue abusada la habían dejado
abandonada
pasarte a dormir en una cama a dormir en
un piso es muy duro y ya empezó a
prostituirse lo que le pasó a ella casi
no la deja pensar ni progresar
[Música]
ya le gusta Hola le gustaba ser libre
que siga sus sueños cantante piloto y ya
quisiera alguna vez llegar a ser como
presidente de Colombia y sería la mujer
más feliz del mundo ella me decía
[Música]
existe
aquí comienza ella soy el programa
feminista de France 24 en un centro de
acogida para adolescentes en Colombia
los directores de Nicolás
piden a un grupo de jóvenes que se
imaginen la historia de Alice Esta
película es una proyección de historias
de vida bajo un lente compasivo y
respetuoso vamos a reflexionar sobre su
realización y para ello me acompaña en
el estudio Nicolás van hemelrique de
quien es uno de los directores Nicolás
bienvenido Hola Ángela Muchas gracias Es
un honor para mí estar acá sabemos que
han estado muy ocupados con los
lanzamientos Y con todo lo relativo a la
prensa de este filme y bueno por esa
razón Noe Claire se excusa y no está con
nosotros ahora los dos hicieron este
trabajo en llave como un ejercicio de
ficción que se empezó a mezclar con la
realidad Cuáles fueron los inicios de
Alice en el 2016 la cinemateca nos
invitaron un taller de cine documental
en el internado donde ocurre la película
y
estamos muy impactados y decidimos
seguir yendo a través de los años a este
lugar a seguir dando talleres eso
termina
sugiriéndonos hacer una película y en
esos talleres uno de los ejercicios era
que escribieran una clase una historia
para la próxima clase cuando estamos
hablando de narrativas
esas historias Por más que estaban
llenas de de fantasía
siempre terminaban reflejando su
universo su realidad sus sueños sus
traumas sus deseos sus historias y ellas
nos enseñaron que la imaginación puede
hablar más de nosotros que nuestras
biografías Y ahí empieza la idea de usar
la imaginación como el motor para
conocer a estas personas maravillosas y
para conocer a Alice vamos a ver un poco
de lo que es la película me parece súper
pero no existe
no existe
es que me quedo mirando mucho a mis ojos
y
siento algo por acá que como que me
no puedo tanto respirar y yo no
no Alice existe o no existe es como uno
común y corriente pues quiere que le
haga una cosa Yo no me las creo que que
yo sea que internet
porque no sé no me las creo
o sea pienso que todo esto es un sueño
lo que me ha pasado
lo que uno se pregunta cuando está
viendo la película todo el tiempo es
Cialis es un personaje real o es un
personaje ficticio y no lo vamos a
responder vamos a dejar que la gente vea
la película y encuentre sus propias
conclusiones pero si quisiera
preguntarle cómo cómo se sintió este
ejercicio para que ellas reconocieran
sus propias historias de vida y las
transformaron en algo más a través de de
la realización de este filme
lo poderoso para nosotros del ejercicio
es que no estamos simplemente observando
las o preguntándoles sobre su vida Les
estamos dando el poder de ellas decidir
Cuál es la historia y ellas decidir
Quién es Alice y Cuál es la historia de
Alice y en esa
inventarse esa historia ella se empiezan
a reaccionar a su propia historia y
empiezan a meterse en ese personaje
tanto que llega a un punto que se
olvidan de la tercera persona y aparece
el yo
Alice es algo que les permite hablar de
cosas que nunca habían podido hablar y
algo que ellas han valorado mucho de
este ejercicio y de la película Mira hay
muchos Dolores que se retratan a lo
largo de Alice yo la veía Atentamente y
claro uno siempre externaliza y proyecta
hacia sus propias experiencias y esto lo
digo porque ustedes productor es
director junto a Claire que además de su
pareja Pero además ustedes papá Entonces
con eso en mente veamos el siguiente
extracto súper bueno la mamá tuvo pues
una violación entonces
a raíz de eso pues ella sí quiso a la
niña y todo porque pues obviamente era
de la barriga ella y todo pero pues
tampoco uno puede querer algo que le
hizo tanto daño digamos la familia la
despreciaba mucho cuando chiquita que se
enoje engendro para que va a estar acá
algo así si me entiende y ella me decía
que a ella le dolía mucho cuando la
propia Mamá le decía es que usted es un
error usted qué hace en mi vida y ya a
veces ella a veces piensa y me dice yo
quiero que muera abortado abierto es lo
que estoy viviendo y yo lo único que le
decía porque ellos tienen una
oportunidad para usted Dios tiene un
propósito para por eso la dejó ir
Cuando uno hace cualquier producto
audiovisual y ahí usted me va a corregir
a mí uno está pensando en la
comercialización y en la difusión de ese
producto que tanto tiempo y tanto
trabajo costó hacer sin embargo en este
caso también hay un tema y es esa
percepción de enfoque de género Estas
mujeres estas niñas que perciben el amor
la aceptación que nos permiten ver
realidades que a veces nuestro
privilegio nos nubla Como por ejemplo la
importancia de las maternidades deseadas
y de los entornos protegidos ustedes que
encontraron
pues estas son niñas
que nunca nadie les ha preguntado Que
quieren ser cuando grandes la misma
sociedad ASUME que que por lo en el
círculo de violencia que ellas nacieron
ya están condenadas y precisamente Alice
lo que les permite a ellas es
proyectarse y soñar y por eso a raíz de
la película nació Alice existe que es
una campaña de impacto con la fundación
Tiempo de juego en la que estamos
trabajando ya buscando acompañarlas una
vez salen en la institución para que
encuentren Cuál es ese camino para
lograr los sueños que ellas tienen
muchos de ellos pues es tener una
familia estable tener una casa tener un
hogar y qué equivocados estamos cuando
vemos este tipo de historias con los
ojos de la lástima y no con los ojos del
respeto y con los ojos de la resiliencia
vamos a ver un último extracto
Pues que su infancia por parte fue buena
y mala sí la pérdida de un familiar
importante si me entiende cosas así
la habían dejado abandonar
Solo dice que se acuerda que a los
cuatro años se separaron de ella que le
dijeron que se tenían que ir ya
y en qué trabajar la mamá de Alice en
reciclaje y como era eso del reciclaje
Alice alguna vez la acompañaba a
reciclar Cómo era Cuéntame
de reciclaje digamos de ella una
carretilla Y ustedes llevan unas bolsas
en las bolsas ustedes coge una en la
botella plástica a un lado de la botella
de vidrio no El cartón en otra parte el
papel en otra parte la revista en otra
parte y así y así recogían harto ella se
sentía bien se sentía como que dices
ella ella pensaba que ella ya era grande
y todo y pues comían arroz huevo plátano
así y agua panela o a veces que comían
su lo hago panela y pan
Ahí estaba la voz de Claire
acompañándonos en este ejercicio de
proximidad con las niñas
y y algo muy importante es que a través
de este ejercicio ustedes nos muestran
otras formas de leer otras formas de
entenderlas a ellas de entender
realidades que seguramente son ajenas a
nosotros en medio de nuestro privilegio
no total pues la primera vez que nos
invitan a dar este taller y nos cuentan
a quién le vamos a dar el taller nuestra
primera sensación es de lástima pero
cuando las conocemos nos damos cuenta
que es un prejuicio que tenemos nosotros
Porque en ellas encontramos fuerza
resiliencia humor incluso inocencia
y despertaron nuestra admiración y eso
fue lo que quisimos hacer con la
película que hicimos explorar ese
prejuicio que tenemos en muchos casos
reforzado construido por el cine que
tiende a repetir como los mismos
personajes los mismos patrones y en
ellas encontramos cada una de ellas es
un universo totalmente distinto con
talentos con unas capacidades distintas
unos sueños y precisamente la idea de la
película es conocerlas a cada una como
son esta población tiende a ser
invisibilizada es algo que no queremos
ver es algo que nos hace sentir
incómodos y la película Por eso las Mira
los ojos y conversa con ellas porque
realmente queremos que la gente las
conozca y se dé cuenta
el valor que tiene cada una y se vea
reflejado en ellas porque por más
distintas que hayan sido sus historias
todos venimos de familia rotas todos
tenemos amores desamores amistad eh
todos los temas de los que ya hablan son
temas por los que nosotros o estamos
pasando hemos pasado y ahí vemos el
valor de la película y ahí vemos su
posibilidad realmente de conectarse con
el público y de pues tener una
comercialización y una vida no solo en
Colombia sino en todas partes claro y es
que si uno lo piensa es que no son ellas
nos con la realidad es de todas las
mujeres porque todas han sufrido o hemos
sufrido discriminación todas hemos
sufrido abusos todas hemos sufrido
acosos y esto solamente es otra parte de
esa realidad global ahora ya nos
quedamos sin tiempo mi última pregunta
para usted es quién es Alice
pues Alice es una joven
espectacular ha tenido una infancia con
problemas pero es una persona que tiene
muchos sueños muchas ganas de salir
adelante Alice es una y es muchas y
Alice está cambiando todo el tiempo una
de las protagonistas nos dice que siente
nostalgia por Alice ahorita porque esa
Alice de la película Ya no está la
película le permitió
enunciarla Y dejarla ir y ahora ella es
otra ley distinta que está construyendo
por la que siente mucho cariño Entonces
es muy poderoso para nosotros ver cómo a
medida que pasa el tiempo Alice sigue
viva en ellas y sigue cambiando y sigue
creciendo
pues mire Alice es una mujer con todas
las letras Muchísimas gracias a ustedes
por su producto por estar en ellas hoy y
por traernos pues lo que fue esta
experiencia de grabación Muchísimas
gracias Ángela y a nuestros televidentes
los invitamos a que continúen con
nosotros en France 24 y nos vemos
Próximamente en ella soy
[Música]